previously on TV sins my people won't
accept a southern ruler what do you mean
you people
[Applause]
how about a fade-in siren audio
engineers I think he ruptured my
ossicles oh good for a second there I
thought I had loaded up an episode of
Law & Order SVU intent in Los Angeles by
mistake The Handmaid's Tale of men how
did he even crash driving down a street
road there buddy Peggy needs to choose
her go away drivers more wisely all
right hey I've been late I had to see
he's finally getting some notice in the
States
go watch the five if you haven't seen it
glad he'll be around to help raise
Hannah for seasons to come these guards
walk up to an obvious hiding place and
then just turn around apparently they
went to the ringwraith school of
searching for things you successfully
kept a six-year-old hidden in quiet
why run out in the open and isn't
running away they're afraid of hand mate
who wouldn't get far hand mades position
her handmade oration take your pick oh
they're getting sent my name is offered
I had another name but it's forbidden no
even in your narration can they hear
your narration damn
as far as futures go this one is the
dystopian Estelle assed one was brand
new it was like training a dog on me not
a very smart one oh she's using the B ID
method belittling insults and
degradation studies show this is a super
effective way to increase fertility
don't call me ma'am you're not a martha
yeah if your ma'aming people and say
you're more Miranda or maybe a Carrie he
is my husband until death do us part
don't get any ideas show presents a
world where Shakespeare's to cheat on
Sarah Walker and that's a sin the
outfits sealed creaky house the King
James language this ruling cult went
full the village in a relatively short
amount of time didn't it Buddha makes
the bread from scratch it's the kind of
thing they like the Martha studio jeez
Martha have you floured this bread
enough do you want crumbly bread because
this is how you get crumbly bread nail
character does yard work to showcase
sweaty masculine deeply [ __ ] also can
someone tell me the scenario in which
this pile of pebbles conveniently ended
up in this spot other than the need for
this chance encounter of course shopping
no Nick I'm gonna knock back a few toys
to rouse Barney want to come on the show
is fletching so hard with this inner
monologue thing that I don't know
whether to laugh half the time or be
horrified I can't wait for the part
where she says she's John [ __ ] toastin
though my face when I can't remember if
I left the stove on we go everywhere in
twos really because often was by herself
at the front gate so who walked with her
there and where did they go
true
as we're watching each other she's my
spy and I worse Handmaid's Tale sets up
earlier that it will be 76% expositional
narration 39% ominous foreboding and
100% deborah downer it said that this
scene greatly inspired Mad Men fan
fiction called the Affairs of Pete
Campbell in this dystopian drama food
isn't labeled so the ladies won't read
clearly their idiot male overlords don't
know that math is a universal language
did you see the advantages praise be the
fighting in Florida must be going well
then where are the pecan logs off Samuel
where are the pecan logs priest a doctor
a gay man I think I heard that joke once
I'm guessing they walked into a bar and
something super offensive and racist
happened gravity of the scene was ruined
because I walked it lying on my side and
got hungry the little baby icons
representing an increase in human
sterility look like tiny turkey heads
this should have turned my stomach but I
was so uninspired by the show I
unapologetically took a turkey sandwich
break the plague of infertility welcome
also why is this class happening with
Anthony recruits and don't all the women
in the bonnets already know this or is
this something aunt Lydia teaches every
day and it doesn't matter whether you
come in late or not you'll hear it again
tomorrow what's it about campus sexual
assault for or against great an
oppressive drama that forces fertile
women to be raped and conceived for
religious Psychopaths and is also okay
with casually flashing back to a
light-hearted comment that sexual
assault is something to be for in a
college paper it's 15 extra sins enough
of you for this nonsense
I just rounded up in one of the night
Burgess I guess Jason Blum got some
branding rights in this time line as
well man knows how to market I am to
make myself clean washed and brushed
like a prize Pig
you know what Thank You handmade stale
for educating me I just spent two
minutes watching a YouTube video of pigs
being brushed and I didn't know what I
was missing her fault her fault
the stepford and maids those eggs we got
today we're nice and fresh for checking
and when Rachel saw that she bare Jacob
young children the organ music the
reading from Scripture I'm beginning to
think this show is saying something
about the dangers of religion guess I'll
have to keep watching to know for sure
nah Karina sex also honestly with the
enthusiasm Fred exhibits during this
ceremony how in the world does this end
in climax I feel like this would go on
so long and so joylessly that the only
thing that could happen would be massive
I'm sure some tuna sounds delicious
honestly I eat oranges and tuna for the
rest of my life if it meant I didn't
have to watch the last 20 minutes of
this episode blessed be the fruit me the
Lord oh they say this a lot but I'm
beginning to think it isn't about
coconuts this man has been convicted of
rape but wait a minute I know that the
society is made up of a bunch of
hypocrites with terrible bases for their
belief system but it didn't aunt Lydia
blame Jeanine for leading men on after
she spoke out about her rape later we
find out this guy is being accused of
raping a pregnant hand man and the baby
died so maybe there's more personal
reason for this to happen but under
their rules shouldn't the hand may be
punished when I blow the whistle what
you do is up to you until I blow it
again never thought a dystopian story
could be more [ __ ] up than the Hunger
Games 1984 and Battle Royale combined
but here we are it sure is a lot of
blood to be spitting for one kick to the
chest and one to the stomach can we say
I'm not sure what this says about me but
I'm pretty sure Janine is my new
favorite character nice
seems like if there are people hired to
spy on the hand mates they use something
other than a black van marked with a
literal eye on it they had Canadian
passports I didn't I got credit airport
this whole Canada is the country of
freedom story thread is going to quickly
become a cliche so let's just go ahead
and call it one ma'am okay garrison I in
your house be careful
first of all how does she know this
without bringing suspicion on herself
second if you really care enough to
spill the beans why not get more
specific this revelation is bullsh
tenshun baiting and I'm not buying it my
name is June honestly offered sounds
more interesting can I hate that I think
that
the whole world gone crazy
chair a table a lamp I love lamp you're
gonna do something or just stand there
and bleed
[Music]
so let's name the zone the zone let's
name the zones of the old fitzy